hopefully you're well I'm delighted to
welcome you you all here in [ __ ] but
also those of you out in the
Twittersphere
and I wanted to note this event is being
webcast and we will be taking questions
later and they can start coming in now
use the hashtag hashtag smartest places
so fire up your smartphones as you get a
chance anyway I'm mark mural senior
fellow here at the Metropolitan's
and it's my privilege to kick off
today's I think very auspicious event I
say our event and today is auspicious
for several reasons for one thing it's
always auspicious to welcome and help
launch a book into the world given that
this is a red-letter day for Antoine
Abednego and pred Bakr whose excellent
new book the smartest places on earth is
just out and if I do say so he shall
rush to pick up a copy I think we have
some out beyond the back so on the way
out please do that
today's suspicious also because it finds
two experienced economic observers
focusing not on the standard inside the
beltway stuff not on the usual spin
cycles but on what some of us think at
Berkeley at Brookings believe are the
most fundamental elements of national
well-being R&D and stem worker intensive
advanced industries ranging from
aerospace to base materials to renewable
energy regional technology clusters and
local regional technology ecosystems
critical there that's part of their
focus and then cities and the
collaborations that they accelerate the
fact that cities and regions themselves
can become incubators of growth and on
fret of travel the world for decades yet
have now come back to embrace the local
the granular and the micro I find this a
welcome corrected to the often
disembodied economic debates that we
specialize on in
here in Washington and yet none of this
gets out what's really the most
auspicious aspect of this morning
session which is the fact that Antoine
and Fred have actual good news to
deliver
imagine that good news but I think it's
absolutely true and this is a thoughtful
settled brand of good news it's true at
a moment when many commentators have
surveyed the global scene and concluded
that America or at least it's industrial
tear is done Antoine and Fred are here
to flip the narrative where the
conventional wisdom seems decline driven
by low cost mass production China
Antoine and Fred see reinvention being
driven by specialized Rust Belt cities
increased focus on high technology where
others have tracked the collapse of mass
production of tires and steel Antoine
and Fred Chronicle Akron Sri emergences
as a senator of polymer research in
Albanese growing stature in
nanotechnology and where others have
seen hopelessness Fred and Antoine have
identified a reinvention playbook in
which transitioning regions have turned
local universities into open innovation
hubs and business civic alliances have
built promising new industrial
strategies in regions short Anton and
Fred of traveled America in Europe and
returned with an optimistic view that
dozens of faded old places are becoming
launch pads for the new I find that
extremely exciting clearly this is a
welcome counter to the scary decline ISM
that is now dominating presidential
campaigns for example and indeed this is
especially noteworthy I think given that
Antoine is a man who while working at
the World Bank in 1981 coined the term
emerging markets and in a previous book
declare the onset of the emerging market
century at that time he wasn't saying it
was the beginning of the American
Century it was a different century now
in fact with a somewhat different view
as you'll see so with that I'd like to
introduce our two esteemed authors who
as you can see from the agenda will also
participate in a panel discussion that
will be moderated by my colleague
Brookings Centennial scholar Bruce Katz
Bruce will introduce the panel after
Antoine speaks but for now let me
introduce Antoine who will present
present the book story and then Fred
Bakker the co-author who will sit on the
panel you'll meet him shortly
Antoine VANOC Mao is a Brookings trustee
and a senior advisor at Garden rock off
the public and policy advisory firm till
recently he is the principal founder and
CEO of emerging markets Management LLC
an investment firm specializing in
inversion emerging markets I should note
that is also a supporter of both the
Metro program and the office of
Centennial scholar here at brookey's for
his part alfred Bakker until his recent
retirement was a prominent European
journalists specializing in monetary and
financial affairs with a prominent
outlook dub for short the Financial
Times of holland he lives in the
wonderful city of Amsterdam but enough
let's hear from Antoine Barak Mel well
thank you Mark for that wonderful
introduction I'm glad my wife as you
said she could actually hear this let me
start by saying that we could not have
written this book without Brookings
booking so only helped us prepare the
presentation gives us this forum but for
the past couple of years was really
influential in our thinking Brookings
and I'm talking here about Bruce Amy
Marc really did the past breaking work
on all of this and it has been very good
work and we should we have been standing
on your shoulders in making this
possible so thank you for that very much
now when you listen let me take this
thing here when you listen to the to
some of the political candidates on the
left and on the right don't you get
depressed I mean it when you listen it
sounds like this country has run out of
steam on innovation that our best times
are behind us and it always have is
problems as mark already said that's not
what we found now let me start by saying
if you look in the rearview mirror
things yes things look bleak you as
employment down seven million people
although people don't write about the
fact that there are 10 million jobs now
in high-tech industries and 4 million
jobs were created during this exact four
point four million jobs in that period
and that as good as you can see that
line at the end is starting to reverse
and it was not just competition from my
emerging markets
it was also automation which means that
we were doing things much more
productively and of course it was the
devastating impact of this 2008 crisis
that we're coming out of but this bad
news we found it's not the whole story
and this book really started when I went
off to Asia and Fred in his travels had
a similar experience I went to Asia
meeting with many and I've been doing
this for 30 years
there's many entrepreneurs CEOs and what
do I hear I hear them complain about
American competition now I nearly
dropped with my chair I haven't heard
that in 30 years and why were they
complaining yes sure labor costs were
going up our shale gas was she
but the most important thing was they
couldn't keep up as American innovation
and so we after this trip in which we
visited a dozen cities all over Northern
Europe and particularly the United
States and there's my daughter we came
to a very different conclusion the
American and by the way Northern
European economies are not on the
decline no they are in fact regaining
competitiveness why there is a new
paradigm for the last 25 years we have
been trying to compete on the base of
making things as cheap as possible
losing battle certainly against China
and other emerging markets we have
learned particularly after the 2008
crisis that it's much better to compete
on making things as smart as possible
and here we're really good we have great
universities we have this this freedom
of thinking that promotes thinking out
of the box that is the basis for all
real innovation we have a great legal
system and so smart
innovation is beginning to replace cheap
labor as the key competitive edge
now this diss rests on two pillars the
first is what we call sharing brain
power what is that
this is collaboration among university
departments but also among universities
that are climbing out of their ivory
towers and small startups and all legacy
businesses and we've seen this all over
the country
what does it be well in the past things
were done on a very hierarchical basis
not very efficient
now we do it we learned this by the way
from what I call the whippersnappers in
in Silicon Valley and and Cambridge but
it's not limited to that we have learned
to do things in a collegial way it's no
longer closed innovation you know kind
of in your own thing but open innovation
it's no longer siloed no today's
problems require multidisciplinary
solutions one of the trustees of
Brookings taught me an important lesson
I'm going to see Shirley Jackson the
president of Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute and she said nothing is being
invented anymore within academic
departments it's all invented between
academic departments in importance
that's it's it's no longer top-down its
bottom-up it's no longer alone in your
garage no it's done collaborative and
finally it's no longer done in isolated
research centers of corporations or the
government no it's done in vibrant urban
innovation districts that's where young
researchers like to work as we have seen
so that's one pellet the second pillar
is we are creating a whole new branch of
the economy the head is old industrial
expertise at the base but now we have
added new production methods new
materials new discoveries and on top of
that we combine this we integrate that
with the stuff we are really good at
information technology wireless
information technology and the ability
to and we didn't have that ability
before to use big data and analyze these
big data to help us and all of that is
connected through a tiny tiny little
chip
connector here and that is the sensor
now that makes various things possible
that never were possible before the
future is all about connecting and
connectedness take the self-driving car
this will be a revolution in
transportation what my picture here
disappeared the self-driving car and
wearable devices this will be incredibly
important to the future of healthcare
you will wear them you can even ingest
them the smart grid smart farming that
fred can tell you a lot about the
assailant is very good at it all of this
is now possible and was impossible for
this is this smart economy this is the
combination of the physical and the
digital economy now you might think okay
this is nice
but we have lost all these industries
well think again we now have new
production methods we have robots is you
see rodney brooks for example of MIT
with a second generation robots we're
very good at this Jodeci money from from
North Carolina who invented a way to
make 3d printing a thousand times plus
faster so that can use notice in
prototypes but in production dr. king of
MIT who found a way to make batteries
all of this will make it possible to
bring back industries like socks shirts
I choose I talked to Phil Knight and he
said we're already making Olympic shoes
with robots
so this is one thing the other really
interesting thing we found is that this
innovation that we talked about this
collaborative innovation is no longer
limited to places like Silicon Valley
and Cambridge it has spread all around
the country to be exact to more than 30
brain belts we call them in the United
States to more than 15 brain belts in
Europe so let me illustrate that with
one example all of you have heard of
Akron but what you thought this is one
of the smartest places on earth maybe
not well what did we find
you had the four old tire companies gum
practically overnight with the loss of a
lot of jobs a life-threatening challenge
and by the way all of our PC is always
based on a life-threatening challenge
then you got the second element that you
find everywhere a connector this in this
case the the president of the university
louise Forenza who got people together
who got people to collaborate because
they had no other choice
and what stayed in Akron but didn't
disappear was the world-class polymer
research that has given us things like
contact lenses that change color when
you have diabetes tires that can that
drive under all kinds of road conditions
and I need it for these self-driving
cars and I can give you a hundreds more
inventions like that that they did there
because they now have a thousand little
polymer companies that have more people
working for them bender for all tire
companies that's what I mean by changes
and so you have the life-threatening
situation universities it's always
university centric each of these places
each of these rust belts that are
becoming drain belts have you
diversities with world-class research
they are dealing with the problems of
our century they're no longer simple
problems they're complex expensive
challenges that require multi
disciplinary approaches there's an
openness forced by reality and necessity
to share brain power they have a
connector and they have an
infrastructure that attracts and retains
them and by the way that infrastructure
includes affordable housing that's why
people move from let's say Silicon
Valley to other places like Pittsburgh
or Akron or whatever so and finally of
course you need access to capital these
are the key characteristics that we have
Albany New York did you know that in
Albany New York just outside of the
nanotechnology complex and under the
leadership of alengka years a former
Christian militia fighter from Lebanon
by the way who became a great physicist
they are at the forefront of
semiconductor research next door you
have Global Foundries that has thousands
of employees working in one of the most
modern plants in the world here you see
a machine I was in that cleanroom with
the Whitehead on and and that little
machine there cost a billion dollars
it's the most modern machine to make
semiconductors in Albany New York not in
Central Park or Korea in Albany New York
the Research Triangle above the Hollis
you'll see him in a minute is here let
me tell you a story on the sidelines of
the Research Park we had the old Lucky
Strike Factory no more cigarettes being
made there now it's an incubator and a
very lively place Portland Oregon here
you see the old waterfront Phil Knight
gave five hundred million dollars and
that brought together the University Oh
Agis you with Intel that was already
there and together they could do things
they couldn't do alone and now you have
basically the university brought back to
from the mountain to the city with
tramways and to make my Dutch heart
heart warm bicycles
so ain't joven in Holland from light
bulbs to the world's smartest city as it
was Gaultier see the old Philips and now
you have the Technical University that
became really an open innovation
platform I will talk about that later so
30 places over 30 places from all over
the world 2/3 of them former rust delts
and in Europe 15 of them well and we
describe in detail 10 of those in our
book these Rust Belt cities are building
on forgotten strengths now and we
couldn't be a brookings without some
policy recommendations right otherwise
so let's go through them I'll just talk
about two but they're a whole bunch more
the first is this we have a 21st century
economy
I've become convinced we are measuring
it with 20th century statistics we have
to stop doing this we are miss measuring
our productivity you know Google map or
Google search is not these statistics we
have to find a better way to do this
the second point is terribly important
why is there all these anger in this
country there's a job mismatch numbers
people cannot find jobs after they lose
them in this new world we have to
develop programs of training for jobs
that are based I think on a really good
model which is the German work-study
model it is a great model we could do it
and we can do it and I think we probably
will we have to reward sharing or
brainpower through the grants that we
give we have to support and build
innovation districts we have to build
political support for more basic
research the United States still does
2/3 of the basic research in the world
but we have to keep doing it otherwise
we lose out
and finally venture capitalists should
have the leeway not to make profits the
next day because then they invest in
social media but in a more leeway to
invest for the longer term
so in conclusion as you can see
Fred and I are optimistic we think that
the United States Northern Europe is a
very good future innovation is not that
competitiveness is not that in fact we
are regaining it maybe the best way to
sum it up is if you look outside is it's
no longer winter in America spring is
coming back thank you
[Applause]
some members cats from Brookings it is
an absolute how's that work I'm just
playing around
absolute pleasure to moderate your
channel it is an absolute pleasure in
this season of despair to be optimistic
about the future of our country and the
future of many similarly situated cities
in Europe you know credit Antwan have
done all of us I think a great service I
mean this is almost like at the
Tocqueville book right it takes two
Dutchman though and funds bigger for a
while to come to America and remind us
what we have right so very very helpful
we have two other people on this panel
that I think I'll just give a brief
introduction they are two of the top
economic development thinkers and
practitioners in the United States
Rebecca Bagley is vice chancellor for
economic partnerships at the University
of Pittsburgh
she took several of us on a tour of you
pit and UPMC last week if you want to
feel optimistic about America go on a
tour with Rebecca at UPenn prior to that
she worked for Nortec and Northeast Ohio
she's worked in Pennsylvania state
government I may have a question about
that and then Bob Gillis is head of the
Research Triangle Park really the iconic
science Park in the United States prior
to dr. to that he worked with Clemson
North Carolina State so if these folks
are really at the cutting edge but I
want to talk start with Fred so about
four years ago a mark and I took a trip
to the Netherlands so there's a tough
job right took a trip to the Netherlands
and you took us to an kovin I frankly
had never heard of Eindhoven before
neither had Mark and we had a remarkable
day where we saw a turnaround story a
city that had lost philips electronics
at the heart of that city had lost tens
of thousands of jobs to asia but within
about 15 years
this is a city that is basically voted
one of the most innovative cities in the
world what happened I shall get the
short version but it's a long story but
I ain't Hall them originally was built
around two companies the one you
mentioned Phillips and Duff Duff trucks
that's now subsidiary of Becker the
Portland based company and they came in
big troubles in the mid 1990s the
Phillips announced that they would ship
their manufacturing to low-cost
countries and that it would have 30,000
job losses and in the same year DAF
trucks went broke so that was a horrible
scenario for Eindhoven only for
Eindhoven for the Netherlands as well
because Phillips is a phenomena in
Holland
we we are proud of that company we are
critical but we are proud Dutchman are
always critical but they are also proud
and that was a trauma for that region
but there were people who stood up
tightly and they thought of a very
ambitions lamb issue more you make from
that region Eindhoven and I check hot
spot on a specific item that's building
high-tech machinery and but how do we do
it and onto an already tells you that
technology is too complex to do it on
your own so people know that's you how
to collaborate and but in sharing
brainpower as we call it and in you need
collegial teams but there was a problem
at that time because the companies and
university
and the city and the city of Eindhoven
and its nearby communities were all
siloed
closed further building hierarchically
organized and if you want to build that
those multidisciplinary teams you'll
have to break them open and in Eindhoven
there was not one connector there were
three connectors early this century and
to start with was one that was the CEO
of Philips and he took the courageous
step to open up the siloed closed
research lab a lab that is similar to a
was similar to developed and he had much
resistance from his own employees and
from people around Philips but he he
opened it up and he did something more
he invested a lot of money in building
an open high tech campus and he books
his own research team on that campus
opened up facilities for for for for
starters laboratories clean rooms and
invited foreign companies to put part of
their research on the campus as well and
what he what do you see now
6,000 research for all over the world
working on that campus that's the first
connector the second connector was the
president of the Technical University
and he and his colleagues went out to
the companies and interviewed them what
are the skills that our students need to
get those jobs that you are creating and
so with the information he got from
those enterprises
he built colloquia that were able to
break through those silos that were also
inside those universities and the first
step was taken by the mayor of Eindhoven
because it was not a Tolan alone anymore
but there were 21 other
communities where companies like five
like NXT like hmm like civil health care
were doing their research and
manufacturing so instead of fighting
each other every time he invited them to
and came up with a proposal to start a
foundation with all those 22 communities
and they decided that the mayor of anti
open would be the president of the
foundation and they gave it a brilliant
name red board and that said it all and
that was what happened in a relatively
short period of time and there is one
other thing that is that is remarkable
for the ID health and region what on one
and I didn't see in all the other places
that was the change that took place in
the supply chain from all those little
companies that were in that region and
it was the initiative of HML early this
century to ask their surprisin ASML is a
semiconductor machinery makers that is
the world leading now after they have
beaten companies like Nikon and Canon
and but they asked their suppliers who
were earlier this century still
delivering components on strict
prescription from as you know and they
asked those companies to put their R&D
in those components so that they changed
the supply chain into a value chain and
that is very very unique but let me
traumatically your journalist I yeah
another question coming a job when the
mark and you and I were in an item at
the end of the day we drove back to
Airport Schiphol Airport
and can you because this is the story of
a Dutchman about the Dutch situation and
sebaceous but can you tell me what you
remember of that feeling when you left
the city and drove with me to the
airport well I'll tell you two things on
the way into Eindhoven I thought you
were nuts this is you're not the only
one this is a city that I don't how many
people in the room have heard of
Eindhoven oh my god well that figures
you read the book on the way into the
city
you know Fred's describing to me
Amsterdam is the airport Rotterdam is
the seaport this is the brain port and
I'm not right okay that's that's a great
brand but uh by the end of the day I
have to say what was the the biggest
takeaway was we went to see the mayor we
went to see the head of the Business
Chamber we went to see the top investor
we went to see the Technical Institute
we went to see the high tech campus and
everyone was almost completing each
other's sentences
and that was it was almost scary it was
of everything Stepford Wives it was
almost like a Stepford wife kind of
moment where everyone was just saying
literally the same thing a unified
narrative a unified vision whereas when
we go to many parts of the United States
you'll don't see one of these actors and
then they'll tell you oh when you see so
and so half of what they're saying isn't
right so this is what the biggest
surprise to me was what you now call
sharing brain power but in almost a
frightening way how much there was a
consistency of focus and vision and by
the way the high tech campus in
Eindhoven
we now know from Anton and Fred's book
in 2014 had 50% of the patents in
Netherlands this is a relatively small
geography but the synergy and the open
innovation is really working so that's
what my main takeaway was by the end of
the day you had you had convinced me
Antoine you coined the term emerging
markets you must be receiving a lot of
kind of emails phone calls from some of
your former colleagues so what happened
that's where I had the tread the
transformation what I always say is that
I quote Pat Moynihan who said we're all
entitled to our own opinions we're not
entitled to our own facts so when I look
back at the emerging market century I
still think that we live in the emerging
market century because the center of
gravity of the global economy continues
to go toward the emerging markets it's
no longer the American but the emerging
consumer data scheme that stayed the
same I had a third point in my book and
that was competitiveness is shifting to
emerging markets that's where I've
changed my mind
because I think actually competitiveness
as I told you earlier is shifting back
yeah some people don't like that but you
know thanks to the fact I'm an analyst
like you were in essence and you call it
as you see it further that's another
question in terms of the acceptance of
this perspective both in the Netherlands
and in other parts of Europe on the you
know you're an observer of the American
political scene or reality TV show to
what extent do you feel that either
local policymakers national policymakers
broader sort of networks of civic and
university and business leaders accept
this premise either in the Netherlands
and some other sister countries it
depends on the the pockets the pockets
you look at
the established parties understand it
and they also see the the the challenges
it's cause our whole social system is is
siloed as well and one of the main
conclusions for me is that the the
situation we described is bottom-up for
example development and all the policies
of the past 30 40 years are vertically
so and you see in it--all region that is
not working anymore so they are in talks
with people in our capital city to
change that politically that's one thing
that's wrong and that's a positive thing
so it's a question of strengths but you
see that there is the same in Europe as
here in the United States that
globalization is felt by certain groups
of people who find that scary
development and they feel threatened and
there are politicians who are who are
are are well wow look a finger on it try
to picture future in which we can go
back along close our borders and and
become we are in a process of unite
uniting in the EU and people think of
the old days that we have a sovereign
government we had the killed and not a
euro that we had to deutsche mark them
and
the Frank Frank and not view and people
are lost they did not get a new identity
and they are looking for that new
identity and a growing group is thinking
that turning back to the old days is the
solution and I completely disagree but I
want to add something to that because I
live in Washington and you hear
everybody - Washington and we describe
this process is really the process that
is bottom-up people are not waiting for
Washington anymore but but and this is a
little-known secret the environment that
makes all of this possible all of this
collaboration possible was created by
Washington 1980 the Bible Act said you
can take research that is funded by the
federal government and universities and
researchers can use this and profit from
it well they did and that is what made
Silicon Valley possible where did Google
come from from originally from a
$700,000 National Science Foundation
grant you know what how did we get to
the moon by an earlier form of
collaboration so the government has a
part of it and then who is the most
innovative venture capitalist in the
United States it's DARPA why do we have
a self-driving car because DARPA did a
competition that allowed Stanford to to
participate and then quickly Google
bought the whole team so here you see
this collaboration the collaboration is
often by prying and stealing and then
collaborating but but places like DARPA
and in-q-tel are actually important and
this act was of absolutely critical
importance I want to come back to that I
want to bring Rebecca and Bob into this
conversation because if you listen to
Antoine and Fred and the words they're
using
connections connectors connectedness
brain sharing in many respects the
institutions you work at now are almost
the antithesis of this right I mean
Research Triangle Park is like a group
of isolated companies out in 7,000 acres
of pine forest right there was a carved
out reason possibly and University of
Pittsburgh and upse and Carnegie Mellon
I mean it's an old sort of academic
tradition that Antoine really described
as breaking down of the disciplines
staying within the disciplines so is
this shift to open innovation and
collaborate is this happening in your
institutions and how is it manifesting
itself they start with Rebecca
so yes it's a short answer it is
happening I mean I think it's
interesting because the connected
networks but we've been talking about
they really happened back in the
industrial time of Pittsburgh you know
when steel was was large it was just
that top-down you know that you talked
about so there was 15 guys or 25 guys
who got in a room and decided what the
critical things for the community were
they were in competition but when it
came to Pittsburgh it was very important
for them to collaborate and sort of lay
that out I mean I think one of the big
changes is the complexity of the
economies which is a good thing you know
has has created the need to really look
at connectedness and look at
opportunities very very differently one
of the things that Pittsburgh did with
the crash of Steel and when the economy
basically and over overnight fell apart
was they really had the foresight to
bring together at the university
leadership the government the industry
all together instead of just looking to
industry or looking to one sector
basically to solve it now is through the
Allegheny conference at the time and so
they've really reinvented the economy
through that time now I think we're in
an accelerated rate of transformation in
Pittsburgh and actually it's a moment
time where our connectors are our sort
of networks are shifting very
dramatically really over the last year
and a half where we're seeing an influx
of young people we're seeing Google has
the most people outside of Silicon
Valley located in Pittsburgh
uber moved their their autonomous
vehicle work there so I mean there just
was an explosion of companies moving in
of neighborhoods pushing out so places
you could not go into ten years ago you
know have are the dynamic technology
hubs and so I think that's where you
know Antoine with your slide about you
know what it used to be like and what it
is I think we have broken down some of
those barriers I really think we're in
this accelerated again transformation
stage of those networks being different
I really think the universities have a
critical role in that I mean there's 1.2
billion dollars in research between
Carnegie Mellon and Pitt going on in
Pittsburgh we can't keep that in side
the institution it really needs to
benefit not only Pittsburgh but I think
the other evolution we're going through
is we are globally connected I mean we
have global influence we have global
connections and we really need to both
take advantage of that for a region but
also to be able to share that knowledge
with the club then from your perspective
well I mean like Rebecca said about her
region it was a very deliberate
decisions in North Carolina the 1950s a
very deliberate public policy decision
to develop a Research Triangle Park and
it was described at the time as very
audacious because not only were we 49th
out of the 50 states but we were we
didn't have any comparison Stanford
Research Park was only a couple years
old when they opened RTP but there was a
deliberate and conscious sort of
agreement that was structured where the
government would fund infrastructure and
education the private sector would lead
the foundation we've always operated as
a private not-for-profit
with a public mission to serve education
create meaningful work and lift up the
people of North Carolina that's our job
and then there were the universities who
were basically instructed to you know
educate a workforce and what we're
seeing today and I think this is I think
this is where the creative energy and I
think it really is more energetic than
anything else it is a shifting away from
that that top-down or more directed
approach to one that is wildly more
organic and it is hard for people to
sort of let go of that in some ways and
I think we're beginning to see that in
RTP itself we're taking a 7,000 acre
site I like to remind people that's
about half the size of the island of
Manhattan we don't have a Starbucks
anywhere in our teepee it was never you
know think about that we may be the only
7,000 acre site in the world but we were
we were not designed to be that way and
so there's sort of this interesting idea
of well do you know how much do we
master planet and site planet and how
structured can it become in many ways
the most exciting things we're doing is
opening it up for wild interpretation
and letting letting the actors create
their own play and that is becoming very
exciting it's very innovative in terms
of changing the old model it's very
disruptive but it's also creating the
great opportunity for amazing
convergence and in a park like RTP that
isn't only a bio pod we're not a bio
park or an AG like park or a net
we've got all those technologies it's 60
percent of the companies in RTP have 20
employees or less so people only think
of the big so you have this great big
pot of things going on and now when you
start connecting them the convergence
opportunities are huge so it really is
about letting go of that older structure
and letting it be much more organic so
just let's follow up on that point and
you know Antoine and Fred should come in
because it seems like as we move towards
this open innovation space
which requires collaboration which
requires people to really engage
seamlessly with each other we're
reinforcing and validating cities in a
way right i mean proximity density
vibrancy authenticity um you know when I
was in Pittsburgh last week I could see
the whole part of the Oakland
neighborhood and Beyond really beginning
to change from like fortress you pit to
fortress Carnegie Mellon the fortress
UPMC to something that really looks like
a city you've got a much bigger
challenge out you know in the park right
yeah so how do you think about place
making as it reinforces innovation well
so yeah we're sort of a hole in the
doughnut because we've got a great city
in Raleigh you've got a great city of
Durham we've got sort of a village of
Chapel Hill but we but we've got this
dynamic growing to get a tweet from job
I know I left out they're proud of their
village a gentleman but you but you but
we are this hole in the doughnut and so
we have this dynamic growing region you
know all around us so I was just at MIT
last week at the future of suburbia and
the whole conversation is yet we love
what's happening in our city so I mean
remember the cities were dead 30 40
years ago right the leaves in why our
teepee was successful in nineteen
fifties and sixties was everybody was
leaving the cities they want to be a
part of that so but we but we can't let
the cities die I mean it's the suburbs
now have to be reinvented we have to
rethink the way they work and so I think
that there are three things that are
going on they I think one yes or vanity
matters in that it creates physical
places that are highly collaborative and
fun and engaging and a lot of social
activity but you know if you look at
Silicon Valley outside of San Francisco
you have a lot of suburbs but there you
have tremendous amount of culture around
risk-taking wild risk-taking it's okay
to fail and start over one of my
favorite places I visited last years was
the imaginating studios of Walt Disney
which are still in the same studios he
picked out in nineteen
t6 they're highly innovative in terms of
the products they deliver but what
drives them is not urbanity its brand
the people who work for Disney would
have worked for Disney Corporation it
wouldn't have mattered where it was so
you really have to think about in your
own space what is it that is going that
you can embrace is it your brand is it
your is it your vanity is it your
culture so whether it's suburban or
urban ultimately have to embrace what's
true and authentic and genuine to you
and really celebrate that and and I
think the placemaking
is so important but it's it's not
important devoid of the people respond
to what the people want give them a
chance to shape it and own it and you
will be amazed what will happen and
that's something we can do in America
and in Western Europe that's not as easy
in a lot of other culture in the world
and that's where I think our great
optimism lives in our future in our
economy that sense of freedom and the
sense of exploration and that dynamic
nature that is you know Park capitalism
and just part democracy I think are
things that can't be duplicated in some
places of the world that have strong
economies but aren't necessarily the
most innovative place it improves we
have done it before what most bill
laughs well level is fantastic you know
meshing and n and really friction of
brainpower and you know how did we get
the jet engine how did we get to the
moon it's always through this
collaboration do sometimes forgot about
collaboration and I think if we make
that a focus as you are very much doing
now I think it'll take a real change
it's not will it is making advantages I
think one of the things too that came up
last week actually in Pittsburgh was and
relationships and transactions and this
is kind of we were thinking about that
there's you know there's those
relationships that you get through the
synergy and through the work and
a lot of things are built on
relationships but there's also a lot of
things you can do transactionally now
right where the human you know I mean a
silly example that somebody gave at the
meeting was you know if I needed a
prescription quick I used to call the
doctor friend that I know now I go on my
UPMC and actually email the dot any
doctor and they'll write me the
prescription assuming it's you know
within my medical plan so you know it
just said it you know so that he didn't
have to use that relationship anymore
right so so I also think that an overlay
of all this is not necessarily top-down
but one of the systems that you're
putting over this to enable not only the
regional or the placemaking but the
global connectivity and so I think we
need to not only think about these
collaborative bump into spaces but then
how do you create the systems for that
scale great that's a great point by the
way we all visit UPMC it's not for the
faint of heart I saw a mouse having
open-heart surgery I mean I'm still
recovering I was going to ask a question
because you know Bob brought up I'll
just make a statement because you go
back to your state government basically
being in the vanguard of creating one of
those innovative spaces in the world
today and then you look at your state
government today which seems to be
thanks for bringing that up I think we
all know what's happening in North
Carolina if not just look at the New
York Times morning perhaps we don't need
to dwell on that I would like one last
question before opening it up to the
audience does all this innovation and
collaboration and openness work for a
broader segment of our citizenry from
employment and jobs particularly in the
core cities because if you go to most of
these innovation hubs in the United
States and you walk five blocks and
you're in an area of high poverty high
deprivation so are those connections
being made do we have the right tools we
have the right systems how do we think
about that well I was just going I think
there's a whole series of exciting
policy opportunities right on that
because I think that
in fact the hardest thing for
universities and for cities and
traditional people doing economic
development is how do you measure that
because it's so organic and so dynamic
and most of these institutions only get
rewarded based upon a more specific set
of data points so we one of the things I
think institutions like universities
need and others is how do you begin to
evaluate whether or not you're seeing
success out of that that's that's sort
of a whole set of policy questions I
think I think we've also looked at the
economic development in the past is
really sort of event oriented and we've
structured our governor's and others to
sort of celebrate the singular event you
know the four hundred new jobs the 500
new jobs the truth is the whole economy
living is far more dynamic than that
today we're going to see companies grow
and lose employment and it doesn't
necessarily say anything about the place
you live and economic development is
less about specific events it's much
more about a longer term process and so
how you how you react to those new
pieces and the policies that you need
both in cities and in universities and
in government to really take advantage
of that process oriented approach Bruce
clearly the answer to your question is
not yet right right
I mean clearly a lot of people feel left
behind and they have good reason to feel
that behind because there is this we are
no longer in an era of job losses that's
the past so that's the rearview mirror
because just as we lost seven million
jobs we created 4.4 million jobs there
are ten million jobs now in this
high-tech sector Brookings research has
shown these are not just jobs for PhDs
and college graduates although by the
way that employment has grown No half of
those jobs if I remember the numbers I
think Marty did that research are for
people whose post-secondary skill the
problem is those who have less than
posts
secondary skills I mean we need to
activate in Durham you're doing that for
example the community colleges to go
back to what they were founded for not
to get you into college that if you can
find but but work together with
corporations to work together with the
government and finally there is going to
be you know for those left behind now in
the end this is not an economic issue in
the end this requires a political
solution do we as a country have the
guts and the sense of of solidarity to
do that and that is at the moment very
much an open question because as I said
that you know I think in economic
development we really embraced rising
tide you know lifts all boats for many
many years and I think over the last
year or so too
there's been a real recognition and I
think it's still evolving and changing
but that's actually not working and it
certainly lifted some boats but it did
not with all those so dedicated
strategies into disconnected communities
where you can connect to the new economy
and a lot of the work that I've done
we're leveraging the work that already
has so at the University of Pittsburgh
is the current example you know we have
a Social Work program we have pharmacy
programs dental programs they're all
working in these communities connecting
that leveraging it and bringing
opportunities for next economy where
appropriate I think that's an incredible
way as a university that we can tie that
in so I think working with the people
that are already working in those
neighborhoods and figuring out how
workforce development it what are the
needs educating parents so that they're
you know counseling their children in a
way that leads towards opportunities in
this next economy so I think those are
some of the things that we've been
working on but I think there's
definitely a recognition
rising tide does not necessarily list
all those many dedicated strategies to
move that but to add something to do
remarks of antoine about solidarity and
the way it's organized i think that's a
big difference between the united states
and europe that in in europe in this
point local communities companies are
programs work-study programs and that's
more part of our culture and our our
structure and that doesn't mean that
people are not feeling left out that's
the same in in europe as well
so we have to put a lot of effort in it
because there is a very important middle
class group that that that is needed and
that must not be left to john that's it
it just it just strikes me building on
and also what antoine said is as we look
at these innovation hubs in the united
states and europe increasingly latin
america asia
they're not just platforms for economic
technological product innovation or
process innovation what we see happening
in many of these places is really social
in an absolutely i mean the community
colleges are co-locating fab labs are
opening pre-k opportunities for people
in the community are being mounted this
is a it's much more substantial social
efforts going on then i think is well
understood and learnt the sort of early
ed end of that i think we're going to
open it up we're going to start over
here and just state your name and and
then provide a question not a statement
and then there are some folks on Twitter
sphered who may want to send some of
their thoughts as well start up again Oh
about starting in the middle there yeah
and thank you Rick Rybak and thank you
very much learned a lot and it's great
panel um question the as I understand it
the collapse of our manufacturing
industry and urban flight from our
cities
really cause land values to collapse and
in part this created an opportunity for
startups at a risk-averse and don't have
cash you know a lot of cheap rent it was
probably pretty key to all this
happening to what extent
now that the innovation economy is
taking off and to what extent is there
the danger that land speculators will
move in jack up rents and sort of kill
the goose that lays the golden egg it's
an interesting challenge I mean we have
you know rising housing costs in
Pittsburgh and I do think it's an
somebody said earlier I think that you
know affordable housing is going to be a
key element to making sure that it is
sustainable we still have a lot of
opportunity to work in to certain
neighborhoods housing situations that I
think could be both very affordable and
could help with some of the blight
that's going on in the neighborhoods so
we still have I mean it's it's it's a
lot of the neighborhoods have been
developed but there's still a lot more
development that needs to be happened so
that's of course a very high-class
problem to have you know for a city
that's been in decline and I think we're
not quite at least in Pittsburgh at the
point where we're going to have that
problem really really soon although we
are seeing in the most coveted
neighborhoods very high you know the
price is going up so I think it's I
think for the most exciting things in
fact is that the suburbs have to offer
is that so if you look at RTP we
purchased the foundation purchased 100
acres about two years ago and on that
was about half a million square feet of
all 1980s buildings the first thought
was well let's tear them all down and
but my wife and I and give the cred to
my wife she's always got the best ideas
she said why don't you take one of them
because one of the criticisms about the
park is you're not able to get young
people back in once you open up the
space and let's see what happens so we
opened a space we called it the frontier
we beckoned all the new pioneers back
all the dreamers the believers the
creators we made the whole first floor
of the space completely open now
there's nothing precious about it I mean
I will say to people in the real estate
business
day of marble burns and fountains is
done keep it flexible keep it affordable
so we opened it up I mean we did some
fun things in the lobby and that kind of
stuff the space is completely full we've
had over 30,000 people use it over the
last year it's completely open to
anybody who comes in the door you don't
have to you have a membership or
anything so what happens is we have
teachers mixing with artists making
meeting with startups we've we've got
the bunker which is the bad
entrepreneurs group located in there
we've created a shared newsroom
cooperative for journalists and bloggers
and freelancers and it has become one of
the hottest co-working spaces so I think
it doesn't take anything away from our
urban but let's be honest we've got all
these buildings in the suburbs we can't
tear them all down we have to think of
recycling them now the question is how
do we do that but also connect to all
the things that everybody wants in terms
of services because most of these are
located in Island but I think it's a
fascinating challenge and I think it's
what an opportunity for our suburbs can
can play a role this is a great thing
transportation comes into the
transportation always transportation is
oh yeah I must say coming from a very
small country like Holland I'm always
impressed by how vast the spaces are a
way to go first of all and then as a
businessman I learned first you fix what
needs to be fixed then worry about what
can go wrong
ten years from now but it isn't worry
but you know I was University City and
Philly Philly 138 square miles
University City is one square mile you
know Midtown Detroit and downtown
Detroit seven square miles yeah the city
is 138 rivers we have so much to do
because people and jobs just flew out of
these cities so the day of marbles ferns
and sounds are done no more Trump Towers
oh good number
thank you very much Paula Stern and
congratulations to the authors the gig
economy didn't hear it once and I think
about the job mismatch which you talked
about how do we fill in the blanks
besides affordable housing for those who
are in the gig economy and move around
[Music]
madrassas like Portland Maine that
doesn't have a large university and
recruit though anything exactly and very
interactive from all the other
demographics that you've described here
today is doing a lot of the same things
they better hurry up unless you have
some other answer and that's what I'm
asking that's really good
well on on Portland first of all film ID
gave first one hundred and five hundred
million dollars a portal Oregon yeah oh
I don't know enough about fourth or main
yeah you're not going to turn every
little town into a brain Belt you know
so there's lots of work to be done in
lots of different places but to know
that we have gone from basically two
spots where things were happening to
already 30 spots where things are
happening that's already a very big
change and and so this will grow if you
see amount of GE talking about
Batesville Mississippi because the
Mississippi State University has such a
great research on also new materials
then you see that this this will spread
and spread that's what I hope and and
brief yeah I agree look in North
Carolina we have a rural economy that's
struggling tremendously there is no way
that the success of the Research
Triangle region in Charlotte can carry
the whole state so so we meet and talk
with a lot of these community
one of the things we talk about is one
leveraging your community colleges
they're tremendous
number two our public university system
has an obligation to serve the state
connect to them you know it doesn't have
to be physical
you've got the virtual world you can
connect but the universities would love
to do more connections take advantage of
that number three they come to see me
makes you want to create an arc CPS and
no you don't that's 50 years old what
you really have to do is go back to
leveraging your own assets what is it
that's wonderful about your community
sadly I would say to many of our
communities over the last 20 years have
fallen to the Walmart and suburb court
of approach where they're starting to
look like everyplace else but they
almost have to do is kind of look about
take a look that what defined the
character of your location and embrace
that not every entrepreneur in the world
wants to live downtown some would love
to live in small towns that have
bicycles and great places to eat that
are connected to the world and I think
Brookings and other policy places can
help provide tools to small communities
a set of things to strive for what are
the measures they could reach for many
of them need those kinds of metrics and
tools and resources but we're not going
to get to everybody but we can make a
difference for some you know one and
this does have a college in it but one
of the examples of that leveraging you
know kind of small-town us as I moved
from Oberlin Ohio to to Pittsburgh a
year ago and Overland actually it's been
a really interesting job you know they
don't have a research institution of
course they have a strong University but
of really leveraging that their
reputation of sustainability of you know
sort of liberal town into
entrepreneurial co-working spaces
sustainable focus and so that might be a
model to look at as you you know our
passion at that point I think Portland
Maine is one of the great creative
entrepreneurial communities in the
United States now it has a yeah doesn't
mind a problem
it does not have a state government
literal Minnesota state government and
state of Maine on question okay so hi
I'm are eager spent a great panel when I
think about the geographic features of
our
Rust Belt cities in America there inland
they have sufficiently high elevation
access to fresh water to what extent do
you think Rust Belt cities can leverage
their resilience to climate change to
compete now and in the future with the
coasts and the Sun Belt so I think it's
a huge opportunity and hearkening to my
Cleveland experience we started the
Cleveland water Alliance you know to
really leverage some of the assets there
there's a pact for the Great Lakes
states with the governor's on climate
change and climate issues and really
aligning I mean it's definitely a
challenging issue because our so huge
manufacturing region there's still a lot
of the old industry you really need to
figure out how to bring policy together
that can both embrace that because you
can't you can't get rid of that that's
the bread and butter of fill of a lot of
those regions while you can take
advantage as you're saying of these
assets like fresh water and and other
assets that we have that I do think are
going to be and you know the other thing
is and you know we talked about this a
lot when we were near Cleveland I think
that that these cities are cool I mean
they just have that the hipsters that
you know started sort of that that
movement in of that industrial look you
know and feel and then the renovated
spaces like some of these newer towns
just can never you know capture that so
just as a quick side note and RTP were
obviously not you know we're nowhere
near the ocean that we've got some lakes
but yeah we don't we don't have a port
there but but if you look at the park
one of the things our hipster community
is very interested in and you know is is
organic food and natural growth and I
think as a part of who's we look at
climate change how do we take better
advantage of the land that we have and
use that efficiently so within our 7,000
acre research park we're asking
ourselves all that green grass we've
been knowing can we turn those in to
garden spaces can we make that part of
the living experience can can the food
that goes into our restaurants come out
of the park you know so there's a whole
series of things but this gets back to
as well
a lot of regulatory issues that don't
necessarily give communities the ability
to be that flexible and there's and I
think that's where we can do some work
as well locally to make it possible for
us to be more creative and imaginative
within our urban and suburban spaces so
Rebecca we should have called the
subtitle of the book not from Rust Belt
to the hot spots relation between two
cool spots I've got some Twitter
questions here this is a question from
Laura Putra is a staff writer at
industry week will the new jobs in these
cities approach the number of jobs lost
to offshoring and automation what like
that I think again brookings has done
more research on this but will it yes
has it no I mean this takes time I mean
we did a lot of outsourcing we did a lot
of damage and to repair damage you don't
do overnight but as I said you know we
have an economy now that is 10 million
10 million of high-tech jobs in advanced
industries etc and that's a lot of jobs
and you know when we went around I mean
there are lots of anecdotal examples in
Portland Oregon for example we go to a
place that was one of these renovated
places used to be a factory ready-made
ropes for you know the boats and we're
about 350 people working there gum you
know empty
you know drug use in the lobby now it's
a spiffy new building incubator there's
lots of lawyers small companies
everybody sharing brainpower and there
are now 400 people working in that
building that's the kind of thing that
you will see but it takes time this is
just to build on that question I you
know let's talk about the elephant in
the room China right I mean is this
changing our relationship with China and
Rebecca you talked to me last night
this very interesting partnership that
you Pitt has with xinhua and how that's
beginning to really evolve so are we now
talking about a new collaborative
relationship with Chinese companies in
Chinese industries I think we can have
an incredibly cooperative relationship
and you know again we have a deep
history of the University of Pittsburgh
in 2011 helped Xinhua University which
is largely thought of as MIT of China
actually start their medical school so
we have at any one time
22:40 Xinhua medical students on our
campus working with our in our research
labs and our researchers and so that
depth of relationships created the
opportunity to now have a technology
commercialization and transfer
discussion so we signed an MoU with just
a few months ago
wishing wha and with tusk park which is
they're related Central Park and with
our tech transfer office to be able to
really connect opportunities that need
because remember a lot of our workers
and life sciences so we need deployment
markets in China talk about where the
consumers are right and the regulatory
environments slightly different and then
also though there's Chinese companies
entrepreneurs that are entering the US
market so there's a lot of synergy
between the two we're talking about
really leveraging that relationship even
more to really create this global buy of
connection so I think that those
relationships that you can look for that
can be creative that can have your
connector role but thought about it not
just in your community but across the
globe can can really help us leverage
Bruce just us as we said in the book
don't count out the old economies we're
not saying any book don't count
koji fine I mean is it really important
country for the future and will remain a
really important country for the future
and what I found interesting was that
when we published our or but we had the
book ready they went to the Frankfurt
Book Fair and the publisher called me
very excitedly and said you know I've
never seen this
on the first day the book was bought for
translations by whom I thought I thought
I hoped would be the Dutch no the
Chinese they got it they got a day they
have been the manufacturing center of
the world now they're just a
manufacturing centers world they get is
that that I mean they know deep down in
their heart that they are very very good
I mean excellent much better than we are
at thinking inside the box they now see
that there's a threat from thinking
outside the box and they have a bit of a
glass ceiling so that there's things and
believe me I've seen this transformation
chen they'll catch on fast
yeah last question there was a right
over here oh okay will do sorry
Twittersphere i could thank you very
much for a great presentation i'm i'm
ellie her it's a former world bank and
intelligence community and state
department person you did I think
mentioned driverless cars and the
current issue of The Economist magazine
there's an article on China's progress
in pioneering driverless cars and China
is also very good in biotechnology so
what does this kind of competition offer
to Rust Belt centers the sentence of
competition shifts all the time now as
I've read that article and sure they're
beginning to develop that expertise but
google has been edit for the last was it
ten years or so so you know ten years
that gives you a certain Head Start so
when it comes to really smart products I
think the United States and to some
extent various European places have an
enormous head start because of this
sharing of brain power what what we
sometimes forget is that political
revolutions are noisy and valadis
economic revolutions kind of creep up on
you and this is what's happening now
what we're seeing is an economic
revolution we just don't get it yet just
think of how you've learned to live
with your smartphone you know how you
now know go to the library to look
something up in a book no you do in fact
in your pockets
it's just just happened and you Devon
even noticed it it's a revolution I will
tell you working in the Research
Triangle Park
you have people say to you all the time
what do you think about what they're
doing in China well what do you think
about what they're doing in Boston or
what do you think about what they're
doing on Silicon Valley and and we get
what do you think yeah wait wait occupy
okay look Teddy Roosevelt said it best
comparison is the thief of joy you can
sit around and obsess about that but
just get on with it just get on with
doing stuff make a difference work with
people make things happen it'll it'll
you know I'm a great optimist in a great
you know and I just believe that have
faith and your people and your effort
make your investments and just get on
with it and things will happen so I want
to end on an affirmative note and I want
to bring Rebecca into this because
Rebecca was part of this network of SSPI
which stands for science and technology
and brilliant and they came up with this
fictional federal policy or federal
program or set of federal initiatives
that probably everyone in this room
would support and build directly out of
this book and then they pulled this
fictional program and what were the poll
numbers they were like incredible you're
called ISTEP was the name of the program
innovation to science technology for
economic prosperity and so it's
basically University Research the
commercial engine that could get those
things out and then the intermediary
organizations these connectors that
we've been talking about and pulled a
lot of different elements of that in
battleground states it was 92 percent
approval rating eighty-seven percent
across the whole and then the
interesting thing as we said would you
pay for it and then the most avant-garde
one we tried was gasoline tax so people
would pay 54 percent and
ground states that they would pay a
gasoline tax to be able to fund increase
research and development increase
commercialization portals and so it's a
really interesting it was done by both
Democratic and Republican polling
agencies and we have the whole polling
methodology so I think it's an
incredible opportunity to be able to
leverage the SFC I and we have an
innovation advocacy council
now that we've formed with that polling
data into all of these conversations and
I'll also end to with the book I mean I
think we've been talking about the these
types of things for a long time and I
think the book gives a lot of
credibility in the way that Fred and
Antoine wrote it to be able to bring
back to our city governments to our city
leaders and really be able to talk about
what needs to happen as we accelerate
this transformation the era of cheap is
over the ear of smart has begun Thank
You Antoine Oh Fred thank you the panel
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Oliver